Peter Kumble Pete Rose's here to talk to
you about m bison and ultra street
fighter force and bison has always been
considered solid but with his low damage
output not all that intimidating let's
see if that issue is resolved as we look
at some of his more prominent changes
and Bisons ground game is pretty strong
but due to him being a charged character
players had to use many attacks before
his specials reducing his overall combo
damage or skip using his special moves
all together to maximize damage to fix
this we've made as far standing middle
crunch special counsel this will now
give players the ability to tack on more
damage while still being able to
integrate his special move into the
combos Bisons anti-air capabilities
don't normally allow them to do all that
much damage outside of an ultra in an
effort to increase his output slightly
the juggle on the second hit has been
increased this will now allow him to
follow up with a second pressure or any
other crazy things bison players can
come up with against certain projectile
characters bison wasn't such a severe
disadvantage that players felt that they
lost a match at the selection screen to
help with that the projectile
invincibility on his DX knee press has
been increased so that he's not as
helpless in the projectile battle vices
mobility paired with his abundance of
escape options made it rather difficult
for players to put pressure on bison
effectiveness to address that the
recovery on a teleport has been
increased by just a little bit
meaning that bison players will not have
to use it a bit more intelligently or
face being punished by the opponent ever
since psycho Punisher was changed from a
quarter surfer motion to a charged
motion the effectiveness of the ultra
has decreased rate and an effort to make
it more usable once again yet not overly
abusable the total charge time has been
reduced
this means players who make the proper
Riva once again be rewarded greatly when
using this ultra
bison has definitely improved overall is
infinity to fight certain projectile
characters has been improved as his
overall damage output which was
specifically viewed as one of if not his
primary weakness although one of his
methods of escape has been weakened his
other options remain untouched which
means he'll still have ways out of
pressure display correctly
you